Consider the numbers
1/3, 7, and negative 15.
To which sets of
numbers, listed below,
does each of these
numbers belong?
And they give us a bunch of
different sets of numbers.
And we could just review these.
The natural numbers,
and you'll see
this used in different
contexts in different places,
but for the sake of
this video, we'll
assume this is counting numbers,
and it does not equal 0.
So the natural numbers are 1,
2, 3, 4, and so on and so forth.
We'll assume that the whole
numbers are essentially
the natural numbers plus 0.
So the whole numbers are 0, 1,
2, 3, 4, so on and so forth.
The integers we'll assume
it's the whole numbers
plus the opposite of
the natural numbers,
or the negative version
of the natural numbers.
So we would go from
very negative values
to maybe negative 4,
negative 3, negative 2,
negative 1, 0, 1, 2, 3,
4, so on and so forth.
Rational numbers.
These are numbers
that can be expressed
as the ratio of two integers.
So a rational number
can be expressed as m
over n, where both m
and n are integers.
And of course n cannot be 0,
because anything divided by 0
is not defined.
M could be 0, and in fact,
0 is a rational number,
because 0 can be
represented as 0 over 1.
Or really 0 over 2, or 0 over 3.
I think you get the idea.
Or 0 over negative 537.
These are all
representations of 0,
and you have an integer
in the numerator, integer
in the denominator.
So 0 is definitely
a rational number.
You just can't have n, you can't
have the denominator, be 0.
Irrational numbers are numbers
that cannot be expressed
in this way.
And so common versions
of irrational numbers
are numbers that you will never
see digits that repeat on, go
on and on forever, or have
series of sequences of numbers
that keep repeating
on and on and on.
And examples of irrational
numbers are square root of 2,
or pi.
And the ratio of the
circumference, the diameter
of a circle, or you might learn
about the irrational number
e, which is 2.71.
And it keeps going,
and it doesn't repeat.
And then real numbers are
really all of these combined.
If you combine the
irrational numbers
and the rational
numbers, then you
are talking about
the real numbers.
Every real number is either
rational or irrational.
So let's classify
what we have up here.
1/3 over here-- let me do that
in a different color-- so 1/3,
is it a natural number?
Well no, it's not.
It's not just a natural
counting number.
Is it a whole number?
No, it's not a whole number,
it's in fact a fraction.
Is it an integer?
No once again, it
is not an integer.
Is it a rational number?
Well sure it is.
It can be represented
as 1 over 3.
Both 1 and 3 are integers.
So 1/3 is rational.
And if something is rational,
it cannot be irrational.
There's nothing that's both
rational and irrational.
This literally
means not rational.
And it is also a real number.
Pretty much all of these are
going to be real numbers.
Now, let's try 7 out.
So the number 7, it
is a natural number.
It is just a regular
counting number.
It is a whole number.
Any natural number is also
going to be a whole number.
And anything that is a
natural number that's
also going to be a whole number
is also going to be an integer.
So this is also an integer.
And anything that is a natural
number, a whole number,
and integer, is also going
to be a rational number.
And to see that, you
can write 7 as 7 over 1.
In fact, you can
write any integer
as that number over 1, which
hopefully makes it obvious
that that is also
a rational number.
And if it's rational,
you can't be irrational.
That literally
means not rational.
And then of course,
you're going to be real.
It's going to be a real number.
And you're going
to appreciate later
on in your mathematical
careers why we even
go through the trouble of
saying it's a real number.
Because as far as
it seems right now,
this kind of includes
all the numbers.
What you're going to
see in the future is,
we're going to start
defining numbers that
don't fall into this category.
And they're a little bit
philosophically interesting
as well.
But anyway, back to the problem.
We have a negative 15.
Negative 15 is not a natural
number, it's a negative number.
So it's not a natural
number, natural number
is only the positive
integers, we could say.
Whole number, it's
not a whole number,
because that's just the
natural numbers and 0.
It is an integer.
It is the opposite
of positive 15.
It is an integer.
It is rational, it can be
represented as 15 over 1.
So it is a rational.
And because it is rational,
it cannot be rational.
And of course, it is also real.
And we are done.